they say all meditation leads to the
path of
Peace but what if that's not true
Eastern meditation wants you to empty
your mind dissolve your identity and
become one with the universe if you're
opening yourself up what exactly are you
opening up to and if you're letting
something in what are you letting in hey
everybody Welcome to LED live we got
Ivan Raj in the house today he is a
co-founder of Heidi healthy kitchen and
also the wisdom Pearl so welcome to the
show Ivan we're excited to have you on
thank you so much we're going to talk a
little bit about um um
meditation this is a word that that that
pops up you know I've heard it in
Christian circles but I've also really
heard it in New Age circles yeah so how
do you tell the difference between these
two I'm glad that you're on the show to
help steer Us in the right direction
what kind of meditation did you use to
do I think you were into yoga at one
point weren't you yes uh uh absolutely
Scotty Keith thank you so much once
again uh you guys are having me on LED
second time thank you uh uh yes uh Keith
um I was into yoga meditation because I
studied in a Hindu school for some years
growing up in India and uh meditation
was part and parcel of the syllabus of
the school syllabus now I'm not sure if
I remember if I uh mentioned this in in
my first show with you guys that yoga is
actually
atheistic and there are actually two
sites in h two arms s of speak in
Hinduism one is the theistic arm the
other one is atheistic arm and in the
atheistic arm there is a philosophy
called Samia which means numbers and
yoga is the Practical arm of the samka
philosophy in Hinduism the word yoga
means to unite or to link yoke MH with
the some PE some some Hindu teachers say
uh universe or Universal Consciousness
Brahma but
ultimately it is the union of the human
mind with shiva's mind the
destroyer and um he's also called as a
universe Universal Consciousness he's
androgynous and he has Bine feet and
this archaeological evidences of Shiva
worship since 5,000 years ago found in
India and he also has
haunts and he is also called as the Lord
of yoga the Lord of yoga are the Yogi
the first yoga teacher or yoga Master
now I have a
question a lot of people have brought
this up over the years but you can maybe
address it because we might have some
new listeners that have not heard what
what we've said about this in the past
um what what what would you say to the
person that's like well I'm just doing
the stretches I'm not doing those things
I I remember doing a show with um
blessings and she said that each one of
those was telling a story if you did
downward dog and uh Sun salutation and
all those in the order that they're
doing you're like telling the story of
that God yes that is correct so I've
also I think I mentioned that as well
when you guys had me in the first uh
show or first time um so a downward dog
is part of the 12
postures uh part
of what is called a Surya namaskara
Surya means Sun namaskara actually means
worship but they have uh used the word
salutation in English to make it
palatable to the Christian audience in
the west so the exact exact translation
for Surya namaskara is Sun worship and
downward dog is part and parcel of the
poses which denotes the worship of this
son worshiping the son and to answer
your question um um Scotty in terms of
you know Christians ask hey I'm just
going to stretch I'm not participating
in the Chant right when we look into
Ezekiel chapter
8 um God takes a prophet Ezekiel through
different places in the
sanctuary and um he shows the prophet
Ezekiel and people can audience can read
in Ezekiel chapter 8 where he he shows
Elders with their backs to the temple
and bowing to the sun it says worshiping
the sun is the actual English word when
we look into the Lexicon it says to
prostrate meaning they did not chant
they were posing to worship the son and
God says that was the greatest
Abomination with church members of the
those
days bowed to the Su son then we also
can look at it in uh Daniel as well um
in Daniel chapter 3 where the golden
statue was built and um the king
announced a decree for people to Bow
before the statue he didn't tell people
chant he said
bow and
the Hebrew uh um Hebrew boys did not do
that they did not bow um then we fast
forward to the time of Christ in the
gospels we we read that Satan carries
Jesus to the Pinnacle and says I give
you all the glories of this Kingdom if
you bow down it says worship but it's
actually
H before me bow before me he didn't say
you chant things to me all he said just
pose that you worship me that's enough
MH and remember the story of the angel
that had the um um the somebody bowed
and he said no no no no up was it Daniel
that did that that he bowed before the
angel he said no no I'm just like you I
can't remember no no that is John John
Revelation John yes reation yeah yeah
yeah and he said no no no no I'm I'm I'm
I'm a Son of God just like you I'm one
of your brethren I'm your yes I'm one of
your brethren and I'm here to serve you
worship God and he says the testimony of
God is a spirit of Prophecy so that is
the text you're referring to yeah so we
know even bowing to a Heavenly Angel is
wrong correct correct that's a great
example yeah so yeah so so uh the
postures are physical expression of
worship and also for the LED viewers um
you guys can just Google uh Warrior Poe
if you look into Warrior POS it sounds
great oh let's do warrior pose Warrior 1
2 3 but if you look at the meaning of
the warrior poses one 2 3 it is actually
the act of
beheading that is being enacted actually
enacted as a POS it's the actual
Sanskrit uh term Sanskrit is the ancient
Indian spiritual language or one of the
two spiritual
languages and uh two major spiritual
languages is sanskrit the other one is
Tam and um the the the PO the name of
the POS is vadra Asana that is Asana
means posture and VAB badran is
actually according to Hindu mythology a
her a strand of
Shiva um becomes a human and um he is
actually beheading his
father-in-law so that is converted as
the warrior Poe where in the West people
practice and it does give health
benefits yoga poses or yoga stretches
does help it does bring relief uh it
does have health benefits however it is
not just health benefits but but also it
is worship connected to it and not only
yoga when we look into Islamic poses
there are nine poses in Islam every uh
faithful deot
devote a Muslim Muslim will practice
their namas and also if you look at the
word namas Namaste it's a it's more or
less sounds the same both means worship
and if you look at the Islamic uh
worship namas they also have nine poses
uh and namas is done five times every
day by Muslims and each of those five
times they have to go through nine poses
and again ear reviewers feel free to
look look it up uh nine poses in Islamic
worship you will see it is physical
expression of worship same thing is also
done in Hinduism physical expression of
worship that being said there is a lot
of negative side effects as well that
comes along when when people practice
yoga it's not just a stretching that
gives relief from back pain and what and
people feel good about it initially but
as people keep doing it it becomes
spiritual and people won't even know
that the transformation has happened in
their minds people won't know that and
become spiritual and also uh in terms of
physical issues uh people uh who do yoga
for have done yoga for many in a long
time like long many years um they also
that's why many yoga teachers go through
hip replacement surgeries because a
human body is not designed
to to do those contractions yeah and
some them are pretty crazy I think bend
over backwards like a pretzel yeah and
we when we when we look into science
true science uh we see that walking in
fresh air breathing fresh air in
sunlight in nature and it gives health
benefits yeah without side effects I
think there's um a a valid conc concern
though is people get older I know this
the the older I get the less flexibility
I have and the more prone to injury you
are if you're not flexible so I think
the question in a lot of people's minds
is I don't want to have to memorize
every yoga pose that there is I don't
want to have to memorize every Islamic
pose that there is like what can I do to
stay flexible without worrying about am
I doing the wrong thing mhm so so there
are many stretches there are
organizations institutions that offer
stretching there's uh thing called um uh
flexology and um there's no yoga
involved in it at all it's just physical
stretches and uh I go to the gym I have
a trainer and he's never asked me to do
yoga yeah um so it's just uh and also
when we look back in even in the United
States when we look back in the in the
early 9 1900s mid 1900s in the school
did you guys practice yoga no no not in
the school I went to but today it's part
of pet in the schools in the in
Christian countries right so how does
how does India feel about that when they
see like Western culture or you know
anyone in the United States doing it are
they like what are you
doing you're you're you're having
Christian Yoga actually very good devout
Hindus um for very good I have many
Hindu friends in India and in the US
also um they do not like the
misappropriation of yoga because it's
considered as very sacred to them and um
so they said why do you christianize
what belong to us 500 years ago the
British stole the gold from they came to
India they stole all our gold now you
have stolen our yoga and you have
christianized it and made Christian Yoga
and all that and so many Hindus are
unhappy about about it because it is it
is their
ritual in
unfortunately um in the west it is
presented as the only option for Health
and Wellness in most almost all places
right even if you go to Medical
practitioners or or
psychiatrist uh they they prescribe yoga
for health and wellness and healing uh
so it is all over yeah so the system has
presented that here this is the only way
for you to heal yeah whereas in the
scriptures we read that the author and
finisher of our faith is Jesus Christ in
the scriptures we read in Isaiah 53 that
by his stripes we are healed and in the
scriptures we have the laws of Health
the principles of Health that is not
brought to the surface in the west that
is buried and Hinduism is brought into
the US actually it was brought in by
Swami vivean I mentioned this last time
Swami Vivekananda and Indian Freemason
here today I think the question we were
hoping to look at a little more wasn't
just about yoga it was about uh
something that often comes with yoga or
or Eastern practices or new age and that
is meditation so let's explore the
difference between meditation as the
East sees it and meditation as the Bible
sees it what can you tell us about that
so we'll actually start from what the
Bible says about meditation and then
we'll look into the Eastern meditation
aspects all right so when in terms of
Bible
um when in terms of the Bible the first
place where the word meditate is
mentioned in Genesis chapter
24 verse
63 Genesis 2463 where Isaac tell sorry
it's written about Isaac and Isaac went
out to meditate that's the first time
the word is this word is mentioned in
the scriptures and Isaac went out to
meditate in the field in the
evening not during sunrise in the
evening at sunset or perhaps after
Sunset and he lifted his eyes and looked
and there the camels were coming and
then when we go and look at the root
word meditate it
says to commune to pray what is
prayer communication is not
monologue it's a dialogue with God right
so when we pray God speaks to our hearts
sometimes is audable also so if if we
don't hear God's voice the problem
sometimes God doesn't answer us right
away he he he tells us later on he
answers later on but either way it's a
dialogue whereas in meditation
it's not a dialogue per se it is a
monologue yeah and prayer is from the
heart you have a conversation with god
you pray to God you converse with God in
in the Eastern
meditation um um it is
actually chant
mantras what does it mean it's the same
statement repeated which is what I used
to do um in my in my yoga class um you
are given uh a set of Hindu chants and
you repeat it X number of
times and you it's interesting that you
find that also in the Catholic Church
the same thing so you repeat the same
prayer or or the same Mantra multiple
times um so that's the one of the
differences and then when we move on
Into the Book of Joshua verse 8 it tells
us this book of the law shall not depart
from your mouth and you shall meditate
in it day and night that you may observe
to do according to all that is written
in it for then you will make your way
prosperous and then you will have good
success so the Bible tells us to
meditate on God's word day and night
or to ponder over God's word day and
night and it is called the book of law
the Bible is called as a book of Law and
if we meditate and apply what we
meditate or what we ponder over the book
of law in Practical life the Bible says
that we get prosperous we become
prosperous and then we will have good
success now prosperous not it doesn't
necessarily mean just we alone can be
Health also it can be influence as well
now when we compare that with the
Eastern
meditation um Eastern
meditation the principle is generally
nobody meditates at 11:00
p.m. I've never seen anybody meditating
at 11:00 p.m. or 10:35 p.m. but as
Christians we know that you can pray
24/7
you can pick up the Bible and read and
study the Bible anytime you don't have
to look at the Sunrise you don't have to
direct your pose towards a son yes you
so that's one difference and um and then
the Bible is called as book of
law in in yoga it is called yoga sutras
a
principles there is no
command there's no nothing called as
commandment in Hinduism there are
principles there are councils that's
it and um because there is no
commandment or
Commandments um the definition of sin is
not
clear it's a suggestion not a you should
do this so I'm I'm
curious what would be an example
maybe translated into English of
something you would say over and over
again when you were
meditating um while
doing yoga or or just meditating in
general in an Eastern discipline that
was a great
question
um very popular chant is gatri
Mantra gatri Mantra in a nutshell is
nature worship
so in the atheistic angle or atheistic
arm of Hinduism you don't bow down
before Idol there's no
idolatry actually that is one of the
reasons my mom you know at the time she
was church hopping finding for looking
for truth so she said oh this school
they do not worship idols there's no
idolatry so I'm going to have my son
study in this school even though it
Hindu school and uh
um she did not know at that time and nor
did we because we were just kids at that
time and this was a mantra that was
taught was gatri Mantra which is nature
worship and um so the the translation I
just want to put it all in a nutshell
yeah um is um the human body you
actually say human body Earth Physical
Realm existence the vital energies
Heaven Consciousness the soul inner
peace spiritual realm
Bliss the Sun the solar powers to choose
the best adult so this is how it is word
for word if you want translation so it
is not a again so it's not like a
thought put together it's it's like a
string of words string of words yeah
yeah interesting string of words so when
you when when people chant this gri
Mantra it gives a certain type of as
people say in New Age you know
vibration and the the effect is real
very real it's
not it's not like oh nothing happened
something happens yeah when people chant
these mantras so the tendency is is for
one when it's when it's repeated over
and over again it becomes
hypnotic and it puts you in a a state of
mind or a brain wave pattern where
you're not really
thinking versus when I'm listening to
what you're saying about the Bible if
you're meditating on God's word and his
law and he's telling you something it's
creating new thoughts in your mind you
know it becomes that continual
conversation with god so you would
actually get a whole lot more out of it
than you would just saying a string of
words together I'm I'm super curious if
if you know do you know if the brain
wave pattern that you are going to uh
have if you keep repeating something
over and over and over again does it
switch your brain into that Alpha brain
wave pattern yes it does so there is an
impact uh uh so now I learned this from
uh Dr James
Markham um he has a channel called
biblical prescriptions for life and
uh he said
that in bible-based worship
the frontal lobe is
activated in other forms of worship you
don't need the activation of frontal low
because nothing is getting activated
here because there's no conversation
there is no reasoning there is no choice
between Good and Evil all that doesn't
happen
so that's very interesting F so the
frontal lob is very active in biblical
Worship in other form of worship it is
not other parts of brain are activated
but not the frontal Lo the frontal Lo is
such an interesting study we've done a
lot of talking about this over the years
just in specifically dealing with the
television what that does to your brain
I I know you have a convention coming up
the the the wise Pearl right the wisdom
Pearl wisdom okay the wisdom Pearl tell
me a little bit about your conference
that you're putting together here that
really deals with the frontal Lo yes uh
so the upcoming conference the theme is
uh called will you be made whole and and
it is a health conference for the whole
being and we actually have many uh
Catholics registered we also have many
Sabbath Keepers from independent
churches and registered and attending
and uh we want to are we going to be
presenting uh health and wellness rooted
in the Bible and we're going to address
reversal of chronic diseases
Through the Bible through the lens of
Bible and true
science we do have we do have uh Charlie
Kirk who's very popular on on online Tik
Tok and YouTube he has almost 10 million
followers and um he asked me he inquired
with me if we can discuss about the
seventh day sabath because he is a
seventh day Sabbath keeper so we are
having a panel to discuss about the 7day
Sabbath with him at our conference
and the health
benefits observing the 7day Sabbath who
are some of the other speakers that you
got coming to the conference yeah we
also have Dr Ben Carson and uh he's
going to have a conversation with the
Christian um uh health profession
professionals medical professionals and
also lifestyle professionals as well and
uh uh uh one or two pastors as well in
terms of spiritual health so the
conversation is again to bring the
connection between biblical Faith or
Bible based faith and health wellness
and healing we also have uh um um
Captain Graham Hood coming from
Australia he was a captain in Quantas
Airlines and um we have um um you guys
had Haley in your show Haley's
grandfather brother Danny Shelton as
well part of a panel and uh we're also
going to be talking about about the E
Impact of Hollywood or the negative
impact of Hollywood rather and
how um the ladies and the panelists were
three ladies and they came out of those
things and we have uh Dr Tim renberger
Dr James Markham Dr Walt
cross um and other lifestyle and medical
uh professionals will all be presenting
on health and wellness it's happening at
Dream City
uh Dream City Church in Phoenix Arizona
March 27 28 29 3 days and um the series
of the these conferences it's entitled
as the battle for your frontal load and
it seriously is a battle for the front
of lobe I mean we see it all the time uh
when we travel around we speak with like
churches or schools or you know colleges
and we see the Warfare in fact we have
kids we see the Warfare in our own home
so mhm you know it's important to
understand what kind of things uh impact
the mind and how that can ultimately
impact your overall health so you know
kind of tie it together I like that
you're you're really focusing on not
just the physical but also the spiritual
because you know why why make the Mind
healthy but toxify the body why toxify
the body but you know all of a sudden
yeah you know you got you got you got
you got to want to look at it like as a
whole piece together yeah yes we are
speaking of Mental Health uh we we also
have Dr Neil nlif coming as well we also
have uh Orchestra coming from vmar
University uh to present a Sabbath
special concert a gospel concert very
cool we'll put a link in the description
below for anybody that wants to check
this conference out if you're in the
area um you'll learn something new about
the brain I'm sure yeah absolutely so
what else can you tell us about the
difference between biblical meditation
and yeah other forms of meditation
absolutely um Psalm 46 this is a very
important text and there's a reason why
I say important in this uh uh context of
meditation Psalm 46:10 the Bible tells
us he says be still that is God tells us
be still and know that I am God I will
be exalted among the Nations I will be
exalted in the
earth so this text is used by yoga gurus
to you know to encourage Christian to
practice Eastern
meditation by by quoting this verse and
say hey look it says Be Still so just be
still but the scripture tells the entire
verse tells be still and know that I am
God which means he is God see him in
action see him in your life whereas
Eastern meditation because it is
atheistic in
nature the god the uh God Elohim is not
in the
equation rather the the teaching is you
are God you are Gods yeah it's almost
just a Divinity within human a very
slight shift of the implication of that
you know uh they obviously didn't have
commas and periods and all that kind of
stuff back then so you know kind of
where you stop that sentence can really
kind of change the meaning of it but
yeah it was like stand back let me be
the God and show you what I'm what that
am powerful enough to do that not that
you just have to realize within yourself
that you know I am I am more than I
think I am and I remember seeing a Star
Trek very final episode that William
Shatner was in and it was like the last
episode and everything and he said you
know I traveled around the Universe I
looked around for God and I and I
realized that the God that I was
searching for out there is actually in
here and then it was just like oh wow
that was the whole that was the whole
purpose of the whole thing yeah and
that's that I mean all those ideas creep
into Hollywood they creep into you know
all sorts of stuff and and and it's just
a slight subtle shift of of how you
interpret little verses like that and
stuff speaking of slight shift uh we see
that in Genesis itself right where God
tells Adam you will surely die and Satan
tells a woman you will not surely die
right
one word one word changed yeah yeah and
and it's just interesting he was
tempting them to be like God right or to
be a God but it was like they were made
in the image of God that always just
confuses me and like tempted him with
immortality and yet they were had
immortality basically right you you sit
and you wonder does Satan really tempt
us with things that we don't already
have access to right just like the
Garden of Eden I mean if you serve a God
that can provide any of those things you
know people are tempted by money well
you serve a God who can provide
yeah mhm you know but we seek the means
to get all those things by ourselves for
ourselves so that's Psalm 46 verse 10
God tells us to be still and know that
he is God Eastern meditation be still
and know that you are
God different very different um and also
in Psalms 77 verse 11 and 12 the
psalmist wrote I I will remember the
works of the Lord because he is a
Creator surely I will remember the
wonders of old verse 12 I will meditate
also of all thy Work and talk of thy
doings so the psalmist wrote that he
will meditate on God's creations and all
that God has
created and witness about God he says he
wrote he'll talk of God's doings whereas
um Eastern
meditation um it is very close to
Evolution it doesn't have a Creator God
per se so different and then again Psalm
119 the longest chapter in the Bible
talks about meditating in go on God's
law um again there is no commandment
there's no Commandments in in yoga only
Prin
principles and
um proverbs 4 verse 20
2122 my son give attention to my words
incline your ear to my
sayings do not let them depart from your
eyes keep them in the middle of your
heart for they are life to those who
find them and health to all their flesh
so God's word tells us that God's word
is also a textbook for health and
wellness and it is God who prescribed
the Health and Wellness
Formula um in the Eastern meditation
again no God it is just a many gurus and
sages throughout the years that have put
together things a your vea I know that
Eric Wilson has um presented about Aura
on LED multiple times um Aur Veda the
word Veda means knowledge or
your means uh
life um also it can be said that uh it
is a Formula or a lifestyle rather to
live forever you will not surely die uh
you will live forever so aure Veda
knowledge to live forever MH and uh that
is actually there's exact meaning but
again the word a means longevity your
life Philippians 4 this is very
important it's a very important text
here because uh the world
portrays as though Bible is
negative there is just a lot of
Bloodshed in the Bible a lot of war in
the Bible so it's a bad book to study
whereas look at Buddha everything is
fine everything is I'll just for
Buddhism because it's all about peace
but then we one has to
think how was Buddha's family life like
like his his
example uh Buddha abandoned his
family his wife and children and which
is why uh because Indian commun is very
closely knit tight um Indian now it's
changing um but uh typically um the
friends that I know of they do not like
Buddha uh because he left his family and
went into search of um Enlightenment in
Wilderness so that's one second is
Buddhism teaches that Buddha is not your
savior it's very clear in their writings
that Buddha is not your savior and
they're correct about it you know why
because again there is no command ments
if there is no commandment there is no
sin if there is no sin there is no need
for a
savior so Buddhism says he's not your
savior so that means if you have life's
problems Buddha is not going to come and
save you if you have health problems
Buddha is not going to save you whereas
in the Bible God tells us that he will
be with us Jesus said that he will not
leave us orphans he'll come back and he
will be with us and um he's also given
the gifts of the Holy Spirits Holy
Spirit uh for health and
healing um so Jesus says he will be with
us in times of trouble and he will help
us
overcome and then in terms of
Peace So what happens when a person
meditates Eastern
meditation so the mind because the
frontal lobe is not
active the Mind goes so the frontal lobe
is being
shut by
force um because by Nature we are
supposed to think we are supposed to
analyze it has to be active but when you
force it not like for example when I was
in my my yoga practice um in my school
days
um I was told to just close my eyes
and think of a candle that is melting
and just look at the wax that is being
melted or burned and just focus on
that and when you do that when you're
when you're visualizing it inhale and
exhale inhale and exhale so what's going
on nothing's going on in the mind is
just that alone is being visualized and
you're breathing in and breathing out
that's
it when a person does any work if you do
it you will feel relaxed
guarantee you will feel anybody will
feel
relaxed so that is interpreted as Peace
p peace right however in in actual Hindu
teachings the word is called
Bliss it's a state of
bliss now let's take bible-based
meditation what happened in the life of
of Daniel when he was thrown in the
Lion's
Den did he get scared of the Lions no he
meditate upon God's word and upon God
day and
night and then we look into the life of
Steven he was being stoned to death when
he was being stoned to death he prayed
for his uh
persecutors he prayed the same prayer
that Jesus prayed father forgive them
for they know not what they're doing and
when they were persecuting when he was
being killed he had perfect peace and
Jesus says to us has promised to us that
I will give you the
peace that the world cannot give not
like the world the way World gives you
peace but I will give you my peace so
that is the kind of Peace Daniel Isaiah
and the prophets and the Patriarchs of
old and also in in the New Testament the
disciples and then fast forward we go
into the Protestant Reformation when
people were being burnt at stake they
prayed for the people this happened just
500 years ago
approximately they had peace that peace
comes from God It's Supernatural peace a
peace that passes all understanding
peace surpasses the all understanding
that's right and that peace also
develops your character you have courage
you have love you have patience you have
humility you have you endure it you
endure the pain so all of this comes
with that peace that surpasses
all
understanding so these there are two
different pieces so how how how is this
piece being activated then how is a
person getting peace when they meditate
very simple logic actually so pineal
gland is here for all in all our brains
so it has it it sends out the hormone
melatonin when when it is
dark at sunset
it starts sending out
melatone and we sleep and that's how we
sleep we relax in our sleep and we get
up in the morning right at Sunrise why
at Sunrise because it gets Disturbed the
Melatonin so um um so the pineal gland
stops sending the Melatonin so then we
are awake now if
we shut or by force um arrest the
frontal L from thinking about anything
in other words emptying the mind they
say right emptying the mind is nothing
but stop analyzing
things then the Pinal gland will assume
oh this person is going to sleep or we
yeah he's in bed perhaps so let's send
the hormone melatonin out so that is
what relaxes the person when they do the
Eastern
meditation okay that's why it's called a
state of bliss with this you go out and
try to tackle the problems in your life
it is very difficult you may be at peace
handling people you may not get angry
perhaps but the solution is not found
because you're on your own MH God is not
in your life MH you just following your
heart your instinct your intuitions but
not God's voice God's uh word is
completely shunned so big difference
between bible-based meditation and
Eastern meditation two different
Pathways it's almost like spiritually
going to
sleep based on that description which is
fascinating when you look at like
chapters like Matthew 25 you have the
wise and and sleeping you know sleeping
versions wise versions yeah they're
sleeping and uh it's kind of a
fascinating little tie but yeah
yeah there are also Buddhist uh you know
Buddhist uh mongs or not just mongs but
they um spiritual leaders who have done
long hours of
meditation and they don't know I mean
they cannot eat on their own somebody
has to go and feed them oh wow uh yeah
and um people who practice meditations
for long meditation Eastern meditation
for long periods of
time um for a while they will have gut
issues I have heard this over and over
again but uh when you go into history
and look at Buddha's life uh he was
practicing meditation yoga meditation or
Buddhist Meditation as they say now um
and he died
of gut issues mhm after 30 years his gut
became weak he couldn't digest certain
types of foods and he died
not only him there are other yoga gurus
also who died very
early um in in their lives because of
prolonged periods
of um mind being shut or the frontal
lobe because it's a mind and gut
connection so when the brain goes
through tremendous amount of stress for
that Peri of that kind of Peri of time
it it weakens the
gut which is why even today people into
yoga they have gut issues if they have
been practicing it for a while they will
have gut issues I thought that's because
Indian food is really
spicy no no no I have yet to go to India
and try the spicy food I I actually want
to I've been to India I didn't try the
spicy food though I heard they can they
can make you sweat yeah my brother did
and he got enough yeah you probably try
it once that's good no
yeah so in Philippians chapter
4 verse 8 the Bible tells us finally
Brethren whatever things are true
whatever things are noble whatever
things are just whatever things are pure
whatever things are lovely whatever
things are of good report if frontal Lo
is activated if condition mhm there is
any virtue and if the there is anything
praiseworthy
meditate on these things yeah yeah the
Bible tells say there is good and evil
in this world but meditate on
positivity meditate on good if there is
any virtue and if if it is worthy of
Praise Eastern meditation teaches all is
well other translations is um transl
that word meditate as think which is
really what the Bible is asking to do
think not not go to sleep don't don't
check out but think right yeah it's not
something that your your involuntary
action is just saying something out of
your mouth but you're just doing it out
of sheer habit like when you really
think about something you sit back slow
down take a look at it you digest it in
a whole different way than just spitting
off you know something you've recited
absolutely um yeah so I'm also I also
Keith I also um looked into lexicon for
the word meditate it says it's uh the
root word is logical to
analyze so again the frontal lobe has to
be put to work uh to choose good and to
reject what is not good in the Eastern
meditation all is well there's nothing
called as Sin and bad things which is
why you know people who are deep into
New Age um they don't like to hear
anything negative from anybody uh oh
don't use the word oh don't if you name
a certain sickness they'll say no no
don't say it um so it's also connected
to Law of Attraction as well which is
also rooted in in a school of Hinduism
when we look at it
deeply um so they're all from the same
um yeah School Hindu school yeah you
know you're you're bringing up an
interesting point because we we uh
talked a little bit about Katy Perry at
the Super Bowl she said a prayer
backstage of of people and and be right
before she said the prayer she told
everybody we only want positive things
in this room nobody say anything
negative I want only positive words and
it's like it's interesting to me because
you know I she's probably blending a lot
of new AG type stuff in there but they
realize the Power of Words it's in a lot
of stuff too you find it in like
business books or business ventures you
know like multi-level marketing they're
always like you know when you go home if
you want to achieve this goal you have
to put up the posters of the Fast Cars
and the fancy homes like no negative
things you it's like you're all focused
on only what is positive and it's that
same idea of Law of Attraction you know
you're trying to put out in the universe
yeah what you want so it'll come back to
you yeah but you know like I like
Philippians 48 because it really
realigns you to say you know whatever
things are pure pure is not like selfish
I just want a Ferrari or a Lamborghini
you know what I mean like like it's
describing these things that are not
selfish you know they're just love is
very reciprocal between two people give
and take you know and it's like not just
me yeah that chapter is very interesting
and when I've looked at it before
sometimes I read that and I'm like
should I even watch the news I mean
right it doesn't really actually no I I
I we should we should know to a certain
degree what's going on but if you only
watch the news I think that has a I
think it has negative effect it does on
your on your psyche and I think like
you're constantly focused on the worst
thing in the world and and I've heard
people describe it like those bad things
don't happen near you and and it and it
kind of operates like when you see or
hear somebody like you know went through
this huge natural disaster and all the
crazy things that that goes on then you
psychologically in your mind you think
well that's not happening to me I'm I'm
I'm not doing so bad you know and it's
like you feel better or something but
enough of those negative things I don't
see how that can't pull you down in a
mindset I think it does so yeah I'm all
for being informed but I think it can
take its toll for sure and uh Colossians
chapter
3 verse one and two if again if then you
were raised with
Christ seek those things which are above
which Christ sorry where Christ is
sitting at the right hand of God set
your mind on things above not on the
things on the
earth also
opposite um uh Eastern meditation
teaches opposite to it because again
there is no God you look within yourself
there is salvation found within the
human
itself and um in the again Bible
meditation the prefrontal cortex is full
active prefrontal cortex has nine
functions empathy Insight response
flexibility emotion regulation body
regulation
morality intuition attuned communication
peer
modulation whereas in the lyic
brain so the the Eastern meditation
bypasses
this uh uh uh prefrontal cortex and it
goes to the lyic brain some people call
it also so an um animal brain lizard
brain because this is what makes us
human mhm right so it bypasses this and
goes to the to the lyic system the limic
brain where it's just emotions there so
people are emotional that's why people
cry weep uh when they when they are
doing Kundalini Yoga for example or in
certain types of Christian worship also
uh you will see that people weep people
people laugh right you you might have
seen in churches people laugh because
that's um because the the approach in
those churches are unfortunately um you
know used they use the name Jesus in the
worship but the approach is based on
Eastern angles uh which triggers the
emotions of uh people um and also um
there is a uh you know a fight sorry
fight flight freeze stress
response and another reason why when
people start doing Eastern meditation
many of them exhibit anger problems they
will have anger
problems
um and then it also limic bin also
thinks am I safe do people want me am I
rejected am I accepted
so so that's all happens all emotions
here so the law is not uh
considered um because all of the actions
come from emotions so that's another
difference and um according to
lifeway.com uh when people study the
Bible feeling lonely drops by 30% anger
issues drop by 32% when we study the
Bible uh bitterness and relationships
drop 40% alcoholism drops
57% sex out of marriage drops
68% feeling spiritually St stagnant
drops 60% reading pornography drops 61%
sharing your faith jumps
200% and discipling others jumps to
230% and that's according to life a
research benefits of reading the Bible
and then there's a chart which I would
like to show it is a research by
Francisco Ramirez he's a um a researcher
and um according to his research which
is actually almost two decades worth of
his research people who do not do
anything to overcome anxiety have the
highest anxiety levels people who
practice Eastern meditation have uh
lesser anxiety levels compared to those
who don't know anything about it
and then people who practice yoga and
people who do pray uh who pray prayer as
necessarily doesn't not a Christian
prayer necessarily but any form of
prayer it says that they more or less
are equal actually um in terms of um
helping overcome anxiety levels however
the people who are into Bible
studies have the least anxiety Lev
according to his
research and um I asked him when we say
Bible study are they offering Bible
study or or the receiving Bible study to
help overcome anxiety levels he said
that even if somebody reads 10 verses
from Proverbs every
day that is helping people or has helped
people overcome
anxiety I love it just do the Daniel
challenge right try it for a certain
amount of time m you know put it to the
test I you I think God's I think God's
the kind of God that would would welcome
that you know taste and test see that
the the Lord is good like do these
things and you'll see the result of it
there's plenty of people have a high
anxiety levels so you know it's a it's
an easy thing to do try it out yeah you
see if it helps it's hard not to in this
world that is constantly pushing leaning
you know confusing and and we live in a
very chaotic world
um I I've certainly enjoyed sabbaths
where I able to completely unplug I
don't think about work I don't think
about you know those kind of things and
I just spend time with my family go out
of Nature and it's been an absolute like
joy in my life and you know I talk with
people all the time whatever I make
every day Sabbath but you work every day
like you know you you don't get that one
day that you actually seriously get to
take a break it's not as special it's
not it's not and I think that that God
instituted that because you know he knew
that we would work ourselves into the
groundh yes that being said in
conclusion 2 Timothy chapter 3 verse
1617 all scripture is given by
inspiration of God and is profitable for
Doctrine for reprove for correction for
instruction in righteousness amen that
the man of God may be complete thorough
F equipped for every good
work so we have God God is
love and he has given us his word for
our health and well-being he is the
author and finisher of our faith and as
we meditate upon his
word uh the frontal lobe is put to work
to choose good to choose righteousness
to choose to meditate on his word and um
that will help us to be called as Sons
and Daughters of
God that will also help us to have peace
that surpasses all understanding which
Christ Alone can give to
ush on the other hand Eastern
meditation again is atheistic there is
no law and it's all rituals there is no
dialogue it's monologue You're just
talking to thin air but you will have a
certain kind of energy around you that
you
attract uh presence of
Shiva it will happen so and and also
when people get accustomed to this this
part this type of meditation it's not
easy for them to come out of it people
cannot come out of it quickly unless God
With God all things are possible yes
miracles do happen but in a normal sense
people cannot just like that okay
tomorrow on I'm not going to meditate
people cannot do that because it is very
addictive MH um whereas the biblical or
Bible based meditation is not addictive
you do it out of love you enjoy it here
it's an addiction what is an addiction
it's an addiction is something that
holds you forces you of sorts you're
choosing but it's something that holds
you really and gives you no sustainable
long-term satisfaction in that activity
like you you keep coming back to it so
if you're addicted to you know junk food
basically you're going to keep coming
back to the junk food and trying to like
get this like fix rather than you just
eat some carrots and some apples and
some good food it'll sustain you yeah
yeah so if you again speaking of junk
food which one tastes good a nice Apple
organic apple or junk food Apple tastes
great it has all the nutrients but
nobody's addicted to Apples whereas if
you take junk food people are it's
addictive but it doesn't taste as good
as the Apple it doesn't have all the
nutrients of the Apple has and um so as
as much as you know in the US they can
promote they have promoted in the last
couple of
decades um just Eastern meditation all
over for everything and um so people
that's why people get defensive when we
you know establish these truths and
differences
because for many years that's all they
have known and and um it's also a
business it brings money people you know
their livelihood as well uh and that's
why I don't blame the people because the
American
system has not enourage Bible based
Health in this country till now and only
Eastern Health has been promoted um in
this country and other other Christian
countries
also um but now now we have um you know
channels like LED where people can look
and look and get a get a glimpse of all
these things and compare it and then
submit to the Lord and the Lord will
establish people's plans according to
his way and for
righteousness and again yoga means to
yoke with Shiva to connect the human
mind with Sha's mind on the other hand
in Matthew Jesus tells us take my yoke
upon you I'm lowly and
meek learn of me he says he wants him he
wants us to accept him as our Master he
wants us to yoke with him on the other
hand Shiva wants humans to yoke with
him it's up to the viewers whom they
want to yoke with Jesus or the universe
of Shiva yeah amen well Ivan thank you
so much for sharing this enlightening
talk and uh if if you guys out there are
interested in Ivan's uh battle for the
frontal lobe series can they watch it
online are you guys videoing it and
you're going to have it playing online
yes it'll be on yeah it'll it'll uh be
on YouTube later on we'll put date we'll
put a link to the description where you
can see um um some of the topics and
some of the presenters that are there
but um if you want to look more into
some of these things that that Ivan's
talking about um you know the the the
frontal lob we've done quite a bit of
work on our Chann channel in that area
and specifically talking about how
entertainment affects the frontal lobe
if you haven't looked through some of
our videos look through them go down to
the bottom and look at the ones and like
how does media affect the brain and
you'll be blessed by those we we are uh
we guarantee it thank you Ivan and uh
we'll we'll be praying for you and and
your initiatives to spread the good news
all right awesome thank you so much once
again for having me yeah thank you take
care bye take care if you like this
video like subscribe and hit the
notification Bell so you know when we
launch new videos and drop a comments
below and we'll try to get back to you
if we can
what say that again no no I don't know
what to say